hey welcome to now skychi episode from
my parents house
everybody's got a question Hey
you can ask I J hey hey
you cannot okay so I'm not sure if you
noticed or not but I'm wearing catch
your shirt and it's not just any
catch-up shirt it's a Heinz ketchup
shirt which leads me to a new segment of
ask RJ where I asked you a question and
the question is what is your favorite
condiment to put on hotdogs to put on
cheeseburgers to put on your french
fries obviously you know what mine is it
is a side note if anybody knows anyone
that works at Heinz please let them know
but I'll be home for a week and I want
to come visit you in Pittsburgh please
one of the first YouTube questions is
what did I do for Easter I went on an
egg hunt so on Easter egg hunt right now
don't let me check out right now I'm
trying to find some bridge right watch
the rest of my egg hunt at youtube.com
slash mother iJustine rizz 1284 wants to
know what phones that I use the form
actually I used to have a palm obviously
I couldn't remember the phone than a
head but it was a palm treo 700 here's a
vintage video clip of me and my trio
morning a Twitter message and I said I'm
going to wear a black wig all day I was
thinking I wouldn't have since I met
okay
oh it's video response time all right hi
Justine if I met you and I insisted on
buying you a drink
what drink with you choose what you rink
what I choose and that's it for ask IJ
episode 8 special edition at my parents
house
oh yeah one more thing don't forget to
leave comments make those video
responses and ask all of your questions
on Twitter I'll see you guys